à présent direction saint malo deux
jours avant le départ de la célèbre
route du rhum en solitaire 3 qui prend
trois skippers qui prendront le départ
sont de la région parmi eux laurent
jubert stephen données merak move
scission sur sur son bateau actuellement
à saint malo alors stéphane la pression
monte pour le kiné êtes kinésithérapeute
tourangeau alors oui la pression monte
ici il ya énormément non des et ce
pauvre petit kinésithérapeute de tours
et bien le voilà c'est laurent il est
sur son bateau avec nous et il est sur
le seul bateau ici qui va faire la
course mais qui en fait n'est pas
vraiment un bateau de course
alors laurent pourquoi pourquoi prendre
un bateau pour faire une course qui
n'est pas un bateau de course
voilà on a un projet un petit peu décalé
c'est soutenir le mois sans tabac depuis
un bateau connectés en fait on propose
un une mise à jour une maj un mois avec
joie m aj voilà c'est à dire depuis un
bateau connectés arrivé à essayer
d'arrêter de fumer ensemble se soutenir
les uns les autres pour a été tué alors
ça veut dire en même temps que les gros
bateaux qu'on a derrière nous ou eux
devront faire ce cette route du rhum en
6 7 jours pour les meilleurs et vous
vous allez le faire en combien de temps
le plus rapide ce sera six jours moi je
dois mettre un mois puisque je dois
faire le mois sans tabac je suis
tabacologue j'aide mon bateau arrêter de
fumer
ce bateau va fumer sa dernière cigarette
juste avant le départ on verra ça le
martyre dumas et puis le tabacologue que
je suis à l'intérieur va pouvoir aider
les gens à arrêter de fumer comme le
bateau c'est limite d'idées qu'on a on
en voyant des films tous les jours pour
garder sa motivation à l'arrêt du tabac
voir avec l'association l'espace du
souss et le nom du bateau l'espace du
souffle alors là on est sur la 40e
édition de cette route du rhum
justement il ya plein de grands
navigateurs ici vous les avez un peu
rencontré ces c'est ça fait quelque
chose de rencontrer tous ces grands noms
de la voile et c'est fantastique il ya
un accueil incroyable déjà de chaque
personne ils sont très ouverts ces
navigateurs ils sont très à l'écouté
donc c'est un vrai plaisir mais surtout
il aussi un accueil du projet et vous
verrez on enverra bientôt des petites
vidéos sur facebook
ils ont tous participé en tout cas en
soutenant le mois sans tabac avec
l'espace du souffle alors tous pas tout
à fait il y en a quelques-uns qui sont
des fumeurs invétérés qui à tout le
monde même des les fumeurs peuvent
soutenir ceux qui veulent faire
le défi d'arrêter de fumer un peu comme
moi je fais le défi de traverser
l'atlantique alors que je n'ai jamais
fait et c'est vraiment une aventure
aussi d'arrêter de fumer c'est compliqué
il y aura des difficultés mais ceux qui
fument parfois on voit là ne se sentent
pas capables de porter le projet alors
que vraiment il n'y a aucun souci
tout le monde en est là où il en est
avec le tabac le but c'est d'avancer il
ya un mois sans tabac tous les ans et
donc on peut s'y reprendre tous les ans
pour y arriver
mais alors comment on fait quand on est
kiné comme ça justement pour faire du
bateau pendant un mois sur l'atlantique
ça fait quand même un peu peur c'est on
s'y prépare comment comme on fait alors
ça fait un an qu'on prépare vraiment en
équipe
c'est une course en solitaire mais il ya
toute une équipe on est une dizaine de
personnes très engagé dessus depuis un
an
c'est vrai qu'on est à 200 % depuis un
an et bah écoute et voilà on va voir
comment ça va se passer ça va être
vraiment une aventure
mais encore une fois le but c'est de
réussir ce défi comme quelqu'un qui
arrêtent de fumer qui osent se lancer on
a l'audace de croire que ça va
fonctionner en tout cas on veut faire un
mois sans tabac connectés quelque chose
qui sera vécue par les gens avec leur
portable à leur rythme au moment où ils
regardent leur portable on veut un mois
sont à bord on continue en fait qui
puisse vivre ça de façon continue aux
heures qui sont les leurs alors bonne
chance pour cette course et de ses
dimanches à 14h ce qui est certain en
fait c'est que il y aura d'autres
participants régionaux à cette fameuse
course
il ya notamment enfin tu les connais
aussi ses participants à la francis
joyon questure idec sur sur un ultime et
puis on a aussi isabelle sur monein donc
qui est la première fois donc sur un
imoca et va faire une belle course
alors demain encore un peu de
répétitions encore plein de monde dans
les rues de saint malo et surtout
dimanche 14 heures le départ de la
course